what is it about this question and
signals to you oh this is related to its
a normal distribution have a good
question normally interview okay right I
know that sounds fun making every point
of others but this phrase here right
just noticing that is there often
students look at a question like this
especially by the time you get to the
end of the HSC course and you will have
so much language in your head that
you'll be like wait what is this
question even about a gypsy need to look
for tags like that so you can orient
yourself figure out where on portland's
attitude you can get to know that
information all that kind of thing okay
so you've got means and standard
deviations for the different brands of
light bulbs so they could be anything
okay so let's just start part one which
is intended to be a bit of water before
you get too pumpkin was that only men
that is yes okay so then it's asking us
first they give us the hypothetical that
if you got one of these light bulbs
brand be like that and it happened to
last for exactly four hundred hours what
would be the dead score for that
particular bowl so I know you usually
have a form of the data sheet there
however the former third that's cause
pretty simple to they don't remember
what that is equal to its the score of
your particular thing which in this case
is 400 you subtract the mean and then
use divided by the standard deviation
very good either estable or the funky
[ __ ] movie okay so we can really quickly
work out what this specific that score
is keyed up with me you said it was four
hundred dollars its Louie score what's
the me
look carefully where red bait so it's
gonna be 500 now immediately you know
and it should make sense to you oh I'm
going to have a negative in school there
and that's because it's less than the
average including arbitrate then i'm
going to divide by go okay so on the
numerator I'm pretty sure that's
negative 100 negative 100 / 50 is go so
I have the dead school for that
particular problem now part two um and
this often is the case part two is going
to directly follow on to part one so
keep what we just worked out keep any
lies and the tree a light bulbs
considers detective if it lasts less
than 400 hours the following claim is
made brand a light bulbs are more likely
to be defective than bread me light
bulbs pause for checking we had a look
last week at pair of dollars do you
remember that and we looked at their
scores of different a game of nine holes
where award and one of the questions was
asked to you know RG why this offer is
better than that Gaza or vice versa okay
now I want you to have a look at the
data why do you think they would make
anyone would make a claim like that on
the basis of that daughter up there any
take it when you look at brain a the
mean of bread a is 50 hours less than
the mean of France be and often like the
mean the average is kinda your go-to for
when you're trying to work out decision
is this better or it'll work okay so you
can see why people might argue or brand
a probe where's were soft because on
average the since you've worked off is
the claim correct hmm so some of you
something that's kind of shake your head
some of you are a bit iffy and I don't
think it's absolutely clear just yet so
how are you going to work it out this is
a similar question and then provide a
justification for your answer
yeah Laura how many to find out let's go
using the same yeah sure we liked out
the dead skull for a 400 our light bulb
which is you see why they chose our time
by the way right 400 400 for the
borderline of Detective light bulbs we
did that for bread be ok but we can do
for bread a as well let's have a go at
that now so i'm going to call this one
up to the top the dead scores would be
light bulb because that's what question
what was about and now i'm going to work
out the dead score of the a light bulb
if it lasted exactly the same amount of
time so what am I going to substitute my
pocket on what numbers we're going to
put it 400 take away 4 50 because that's
the new mean on my nuclear azzata or
while I / cool there's a different me
there's a different standard deviation
ok on the numerator I'm pretty sure
that's negative 50 negative 50 / 25 is
okay so this is helpful you're noticing
kind of like oh that's a bit suspicious
that you're getting exactly the same
time were here as you got there that's a
plus but how are you going to skinny
some work if you're going to justify
something you say at least this sentence
those two numbers are exactly to say but
what does that mean well like is the
quite correct a lot so you disagree with
the claim but what many will be you see
okay now this is really helpful that
means you pick that and then I'm going
to actually draw something with the
percentages light bulbs that are below
to be four hundred hours threshold okay
it's going to be the same for bran a as
it is for brand beer here's how I'm
going to convince you if you've got some
space better I'm just going to move this
out of the way a little bit in your
books I want you to draw you think of
the debt draw me as a normal
distribution and don't have to be legal
pretty but we need to be able to put
some in school okay now like I said
doesn't have to be beautiful in fact
does any of us to be big there's not a
huge amount of information we're going
to put onto you but I've got a normal
distribution for a and a noble diffusion
to be what shall I put information on TR
and hopefully try to illustrate manage
exact point that's an age of 40 light
bulbs will be identical let's do a first
so you can see right down in the middle
cuz it's a normal distribution that's
where you're going to find 450 ok so
that's the me and as I go standard
deviations down we just worked out your
400 our lasting light bulb has a red
score of negative 2 so I'm going to go
one standard deviation two standard
deviations and there's all of your 400
our light bulbs okay so you can see down
here with shaded much
down here this is how many light bulbs
inbred a are faulty write Laura's
upgrade is insulting can you remember
enough about the percentages to work out
Watson cents each that activist is not
required but the cheerful is like that
muscle this is going to be 2.5 really
get 2.5 from 195 mmm I expected take
their within two standard deviations
live it too okay what I decide and I
said I'm dead score negative 2 at the
variance within two standard deviations
I have ninety five percent of the
population which means that outside of
that I've got five percent but I've only
really we keep the bottom work well
that's right there does that make this
so that's two and a half percent two and
a half percent of bread a are faulty ok
so now I'm going to go over to brand B
it's got a different me at a different
standard deviation what's the mean have
a look it's 500 you can see that from
the table okay so right in the middle
I'm gonna write to 400 but again part
one's holding that if I go one standard
deviation two standard deviations away
bread be is much more variables much
more spread out that's what the largest
planet deviation means does that make
sense so that's why I still get to this
400 even though my meat was so much
higher so when I go to highlight again
these guys over here for Brandi are
still the faulty bifold and because it's
still after dead score of negative two
it's the same two and a half percent
does that make sense ok so those
pictures are going to help but how would
you word that can I give you a maybe a
minute or so just to see how would you
write a single sentence that would
explain this is why the claim is no
connection because many of you seconds
of thing better be good think of how you
cross that sensitive ok so maybe look
then you're like ok I get all the math I
ill the maps of the numbers at least you
can calculate then scores but you do
have to be able to articulate what's
going on that's what that justify word
means so here's a cheetah delivery I
used two sentences she's the way I did
it light bulbs that perspective
threshold you didn't have to use that
phrase that I didn't have a more
succinct way to say it things that are
right there or below I'm going to fail
light bulbs at that threshold have
identical dead scores and I think it's
important that you highlight that they
are the same and refer to the value that
you just worked out like you're using
the data usually it with reference to
this coral clear deviations you're
highlighting what you've done in part 1
and part 2 in your calculations in your
justification therefore and this is the
other key phrase the same percentage is
false is that is what we were doing we
establish the 2.5% see okay so that's
why the claim is not correct
what would you okay so amount is a
tricky work I think percentage or
proportion or share or even ratio any of
those were to be okay but amount is a
bit tricky because say for example
brandy makes billions of light bulbs and
brand B is a small companies right well
the same amount is not true whereas the
percentage captures that it's 2.5 some
of these guys if that's a lot more a
little and 2.5% of these guys since i
calculated percentages then i'm going to
use them in mind would